hey guys it's Wednesday and I'm here for
you but just unfortunately isn't she's
away sick so please give her your best
wishes but for now here's what's
happening in News one of the coolest
games I saw at e3 was Dragon Ball
Fighter Z and today two new characters
for the fighting game that is
indistinguishable from the TV show have
been announced the latest issue of
Japanese magazine v-jump revealed that
piccolo and krillen are joining the
roster in Fighter Z according to commit
sue while the pair lacked the power of
the Saiyans each will have unique
abilities to compensate piccolo can grab
enemies with his extend-o-arms and fire
beam attacks at high speed or Crillon
can use classic Dragon Ball moves like
the Kamehameha and afterimage technique
the two joined the already confirmed
roster of Future Trunks merge and boost
self freezer Gohan Vegeta and Goku
Dragonball fighter Z is due out sometime
in 2018 for ps4 Xbox one and PC there
will be a closed beta if you don't want
to wait that long which you can register
for starting July 26 was it have
revealed when the new overwatch
character doom fists will join the fight
on all platforms from July 27 you'll be
able to punch hand cannon and meteor
strike with reckless abandon 20m fist
comes to PC ps4 and Xbox one
doom fist was a long rumored character
who was added to overwatch his public
test realm in early July was it also
released a new video that dealt into the
development of the latest hero as well
as the characters morality and
motivation while he's technically a
villain game director Jeff Kaplan
explained that doom fist doesn't believe
he is bad but it's instead focused on
quote perpetuating strength and honor if
you want to catch up on everything doom
fist before he's publicly available you
can jump into the PTR and give him a
whirl right now or head over to GameSpot
where we've got breakdowns of his
attacks skins and cringy slimes ki oh
none of which will ever top this one
from Reaper finally by aware of
announced that a familiar face will be
returning to the studio Casey Hudson the
director of the Mass Effect trilogy is
returning to the studio to take up the
position of general manager Hudson left
the studio in 2014 to serve as creative
director at Microsoft Game Studios where
he was working on hololens he will be
replacing Aaron Flynn who held the
position of general manager for 17 years
and has been involved in all the major
releases from the Edmonton studio in a
post on the Bioware blog Quinn confirmed
that he will be catching her
enough before departing the studio at
the end of July and that he's excited to
be able to appreciate Bioware games from
a new perspective in a separate post
Hudson reflected on the last few years
fondly calling them transformative but
he is quote thrilled to have the
opportunity to return to lead Bioware a
studio that I think of is home and
that's it for games weren't used for
today do let me know what you cared
about down below in the comments
hopefully Jess will be back tomorrow but
if not I'll definitely be here so I'll
see you then